[Music]
joining us now with reaction to the
explosive memo detailing FISA abuses
president Trump's attorneys also the
chief counsel for the American Center
for Law and Justice Jay Sekulow Jam
calling this the biggest abuse of power
corruption case in our lifetime this was
all designed to impact a presidential
election and an incoming president and
to undermine an incoming president and
to undermine an election I want to get
your general thoughts first yeah well
you have to look at the timeline here
Sean to show how dangerous the precedent
that's been established by the FBI James
Comey and the FBI attempted to get a
FISA warrant in the summer of 2016 they
were not successful they men moved in
October by adding to their request the
steel dossier then they get a FISA
warrant so that FISA warrant is issued
in January before the president was
sworn in James Comey as FBI director
meets with the president tells him about
this as his words were salacious and
unverified dossier but said he's not on
the president was not under
investigation and that not to worry
about that yet seven weeks before then
he obtained a FISA warrant based on that
dossier then it was renewed a day before
the inauguration and then renewed
subsequently again and so when you look
at just this the chain of events and
that's what I want people to focus on
the timeline here is very very not only
dangerous but I mean what did they tell
the FISA Court they didn't say this was
political opposition research they
didn't say it was unverified chrissteele
leaked the information to a media source
the FBI said they cut off formal
relations with him did they tell that to
the FISA judge so I think the real issue
here is both as to the nature of what
they did but also what they did to the
court and I think all that has to be
reviewed obviously and I think it's very
personal counsel I think a special
counsel is necessary to review this
entire matter because we're not even
cluding the Bruce or situation or any of
that you add all of that together and I
think it needs to be an outside Council
well what happens if you know that this
is a democratic bought and paid for
dossier and you know the information is
false and you don't disclose this to the
judge
on four separate occasions now if I was
the judge in this case I think I would
be pretty angry about all of that yeah
so you know first of all 50 USC requires
all applications for warrant they're
under oath you of course you can't
commit perjury but more than that I
think is what's at stake here is the
fact that they utilize this information
knowing it was not truthful knowing it
was unverified not notifying the court
of the entire process of what went on
here but they didn't do it wants it into
it twice they did it three times and
then James Comey again going to the
president-elect of the United States and
saying hey there's this dossier out
there I'm not trying to do a J Edgar
Hoover those were by the way James
commis words I'm not doing I'm trying to
do a Hoover on you here it's just it's
what it's unverified it's salacious it's
you're not under investigation but yet
he utilized that again to obtain the
warrant it's not fine it doesn't work
both ways yes because you're saying that
he used this what he called in front of
them president electrum unverified and
salacious dossier two months earlier he
used to get the warrant to spy on a
trump campaign and then the Trump
transition team so the level of
duplicity what which is it because if
you thought it was unbearably both and
salacious and you presented it to a
court and you signed off on it and that
was the determining factor as you point
out it was denied first in July then
right James Comey is a big legal problem
doesn't he I think he does and
Christopher steel by the way came to the
FBI in the time frame that looks like it
was around July so Christopher steel the
the so-called you know British spy that
was getting this information by the way
who was working on with him Bruce or the
number for his wife who's working
happens to be perfusion GPS on this
project so again I say this if there was
a need for a special counsel this is one
of those moments because you know
unfortunately again this is not the rank
and file FBI members you've been very
clear in that I've been clear on that
but and this is a deep state as people
call it this is that this is the top
this is leadership
so again yeah James Comey did doesn't
get it both ways he can't make the
statements he made and then go back on
him to get a warrant I mean he got a
warrant based on this information and I
don't care if someone's a Republican
Democrat independent libertarian Green
Party that's not the way it works
constitutional republic let me go to the
very end of the memo when they talk
about Andrew McCabe and his testimony in
December of 2017 that no surveillance
warrant would have been sought from the
FISA Court but but for the dossier
information the Democrats have tried to
jump on that and say oh oh he didn't
exactly say that well I checked with
numerous sources on the committee that
have confirmed he was asked this
question multiple times and actually his
answer is far worse than what the memo
actually states in this particular case
that in fact they wouldn't have sought
them this at in any way without the
dossier so this is the situation Jay
you've got Hillary Clinton a bought and
paid for and of all things dossier full
of Russian propaganda Wow pretty ironic
when you think about it yeah very
significant yep okay but it's to lie to
the American people to influence the
election which ratchets up the typical
lying that's done in political campaigns
but then it's used to obtain a FISA
warrant to spy on an opposition party in
an incoming president now
we've studied water he's done by this is
fun this is done by an FBI director who
remember Democrats were calling for his
removal when he intervened and by the
way I was very critical of his
intervention into the political process
I thought that was absurd what he did
that that three stunts maneuver he did
in the summer then in the fall in the
election which is what is against the
FBI's ruling where he can plate at his
job as FBI director who became the super
Attorney General which is not as
function administrative layer
procedurally yet he did that and I was
very critical of that but he this is
what he did last question those people
that are defending James count Comey
should go back and remind themselves of
what they said you know a year ago
you're not it's interesting would we
have had this special counsel but for
all of this Jay Sekulow well there's the
there's the question because so the
question is did this dossier lead to
this create this investigation and that
question is a real question I think it
has got a significant legal consequence
and that is the underlying question did
this in this case FISA warrant start
this investigation and again I can't cut
pine on that I'm not going to but I will
tell you this it raises serious
questions
all right well I believe it did and that
that gives justification if I was
general Flynn tonight and my lawyers I'd
be in a room tonight coming up with
strategy saying what Paul Manafort I
believe it should be disbanded but I
won't drag you into that good to see you
when we come